チロルチョコすごい種類があると思うんですよ。僕。
で、なんか多すぎて
味がなんか細かい　きなこもち味とか
きなこもち味とか
【マサキ】うんうん
なんか絶妙なラインばかりついてくるのでワンチャン全部同じ
なんじゃねえかなっていう気がしておりまして　名前
何味って書いてあるから何味なんだなっていう、こう自己暗示が
かかってしまって、本当はクロワッサン味じゃないのにクロワッサンって書いてあるから、「あっ、あっ、クロワッサン
なんだ」みたいな認識のもと食べてしまうからその味と
感じてしまうって言う気がしてるんです僕
微妙な違いは
あるものの実際味はおなじなんじゃないということで
結構いろんな
クロワッサンじゃねぇや
ｗｗｗｗ
結構いろんなチロルチョコを準備してあるので、あっちの冷蔵庫に
今回検証したいのはチロルチョコの味がわからない
僕に何か一つチロルチョコを食べさせてください
でそのあと、
好きな味で言ってください
本当ににその味でもいいし
違う味でもいい
要するに何味かを適当に僕に言って、それがその味なのか、　または
違う味なのかを僕が当てます。
これで全然当たらなかったらもうチロルチョコは完全に
全部同じｗｗｗｗ
ｗｗｗｗ
怒られるんじゃない？これ
っていう可能性もあるかも
そこを僕が検証していこうと思います
ではいこう！よしこーい！
まさき）はい、いきまーす
はじめ）はい
まさき）これは、ミルク味です
はじめ）ミルク味？で、ほんとにただのミルクだよね？
まさき）うん。
はじめ）牛乳の味じゃん
うぶぇえええ
はじめ）ん〜〜
うわなんか
はじめ）ん〜〜なるほどね　ふむふむ
はじめ）はい、はい、整いました。これは、
ミルク味です
マサキ】ファイナルアンサー？
ファイナル・・あんた
はじめ）よっしゃーーー！！！　　【マサキ】普通に当てたｗｗ
基本的な味はわかるよさすがに、今のは分かりやすかった。
ミルク味って言われたら「あ、ミルク味なんだな」って思って食べたらミルク味だった。今のは
まさき）なるほどね、じゃあ２つ目
はじめ】ウェッヘッへ(咳)
まさき）次は
クロワッサンです
はじめ）クロワッサン？！わかりましたｗｗ
はじめ）うわっ、なにこれ分かんなｗ
ん～？
美味しいけど・・・こう・・・
確固たるクロワッサン要素が見いだせぬ
はじめ）うわー、まじか
はい、整いました
まさき）では、どうぞ
はじめ）えー、今のは、
クロワッサン味です。
ファイナルアンサー？
はじめ）えっ？えっ？うそうそっ？うそっ？
まさき）クロワッサンじゃないですね
はじめ）いや、絶対クロワッサンでしょ今の
まさき）逆に当ててほしい何味か。正解
まさき）THE　セブンシュー
セブンのシュークリームの
【はじめ】ふ・・・
まさき）はーい、次これでーす。
あ・・・なんかヌルヌルしてる
はじめ）はい、はい、はい、整いました。　え〜
おそらく、イチゴ味だと思います
まさき）ただ、
ただのストロベリー味じゃない、さっきのヌルヌル
はじめ）え、当てていい？
マサキ】ストロベリーだけじゃないんだよね
【マサキ】違う違う違うｗｗｗ
ｗｗｗｗｗ
はじめ】わかんない✕2
はじめ）いちごミルクでしょ？
まさき）ちがう...
【はじめ】なになになに？
正解は、いちごゼリー！ストロベリーゼリーでした！
はじめ）ふー ん
はじめ）よしこーい！
まさき）これは、
【はじめ】ボイ！！
セブンシュー味
はじめ）戻ってきたな、セブンシュー味ね、OK
シャキーン【噛む音】
はじめ）あ！わかりました。　セブンシュー味ではなく、
クロワッサン味です！
まさき）せいか〜い！！